the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so this next exercise is which of the
following is allowed in Python so X plus
y is equal to two and again these are
all things that you can just type in to
put into anaconda which is our IDE for
the class and see whether whether it
works or not so this the first one is
probably not right increase it a little
bit it's not right because the left side
needs to be a variable this is not right
because it's an expression this is not
right because 2 is not a proper variable
name and XY that one's actually going to
be okay because it's not multiplication
it's just the variable XY okay so 50%
said XY is equal to 2 and that's right
ok so none of these yeah so just to make
sure that you guys understand X X Y this
last one here is the right one because
XY is not x times y like in math it's
best one variable name that has two
characters x and y okay